[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality host
of the Dr John deloney show and number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today as we take your questions about
your life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Chelsea starts this hour off in
Mobile Alabama Hi Chelsea how are you
hey Dave good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
well thank you so much for taking this
call it really means a lot to me I
actually sent this question in after
watching y'all's smart conference in
Nashville a few weeks ago and it just
meant a lot that y'all reached out to
have me ask this question live so
um I guess I'll get right into it I've
been
um working the baby steps since 2019
I've paid off 32 000 worth of credit
card debt in my car it's good for you to
never have a car note yeah thank you
hope to never have a car note ever again
um I still owe 72 000 in student loan
debt
um I currently rent in Alabama
um and my husband I'm married my husband
lives in Maryland and we own a house in
Maryland he works for the railroad and
he hasn't been able to find
Opportunities equivalent to what he has
right now in Maryland long story short I
lived in Maryland for five years that's
where I met him I'm a person in recovery
from substance use I moved away to get
well and then moved back closer down
south to where my son from my first
marriage is so that's why we're living
separate right now because my son is
down south
so um my question is I'm looking to get
closer to my son in Mississippi he lives
about an hour and a half away from me
and like I said I currently rent the
town that he lives in very rural and
there's not a lot of opportunities to
rent there's nothing available based on
the four calls that I've made it's like
I said a small community so my husband
and I are considering looking to
purchase a second home for me in
Mississippi near where my son is and
this would require us to go outside of
the baby steps and we're just trying to
weigh all of our options here and I feel
like I'm in a Race Against Time to spend
more time with my son while he's you
know at this stage of Life he's 12. and
right now I only get him every other
weekend in the Summers so um yeah that's
that's kind of where we're at just
trying to weigh all of our options
it sounds to me like you are trying to
do everything all at once
yeah yeah it's it's been a struggle I
mean I feel comfortable renting you know
I'd be fine to rent if I were closer to
my son no I'm not talking I'm not
talking about money I'm talking about
you're trying to do a long distance
marriage you're you're really right now
trying to do long-distance parenting
yeah and you're trying to clean up your
finances and you're trying to stay sober
you're trying to do a lot of stuff all
at the same time I'm afraid all this is
going to implode on itself you're asking
a lot of you
yeah yeah it is a lot I mean it's too
much um I feel yeah I feel like you know
if if I could get in a second house and
to say to my husband and I don't combine
finances at least not now we're not
against it we just us living separate
it's just made sense for us not to put
our finances together and that may be
wrong you know maybe stop a second
because yeah I I appreciate that you
need to be near your 12 year old
yeah but you need to be near your
husband more
it's more important yeah yeah and
there's nothing in this conversation has
ever ended
this fact that you're in two different
cities I never one time have I heard you
I'll bring this to a close
everything it's almost like it was going
on forever the way you talk about it
you guys don't have a plan to land This
Plane
and that's bothering me more than
anything you're asking about you've been
married 41 years and somebody asked me
the other night how we've been married
41 years is because I told Sharon if she
leaves I'm going with her I couldn't
stand to do what you're doing I I would
be a complete wet dish rag wimp I
couldn't do it I couldn't I couldn't
make it
she said she says if she dies I'm gonna
get married remarried in about 30
minutes just because I can't make it you
know that's what she says you know and
she's right you know so I don't
understand I don't I can't get my head
around what y'all are doing
well I work from home so I'm able to see
him like we make plans to see each other
every six weeks where I stay with him
for two weeks not marriage that's a
that's a fun weekend dating opportunity
yeah this is not a good plan honey and
if you buy another house you're
cementing yourselves further apart yes
yeah well what would be the solution
like if I lived with you know having my
experience in substance use and mental
health like what would it hurt my son
from him not to have his mom full-time
you know what I'm saying like it's just
a temporary thing that I'm wanting to
spend this time with my son until he's
grown you know well it's only six years
five years yes five to six years yeah
and your marriage is dust
yeah
yeah and it's it's not so much of a
marriage right now like it let me put it
this way
um I know firsthand people close to me
that I love and care about who are
married to the railroad okay
my wife said I have to leave this town
in order to stay sober and be mentally
and physically well I don't care what my
job is I quit
I'm gonna go with her
and so right now as far as I'm concerned
he is choosing he's married to his job
more than he's married to his wife and
you're married to a 12 year old more
than your husband correct yeah and so
what you're no I would not buy a house
you guys got to solve for this he needs
to come down there and y'all buy a house
and sell the house in Maryland and until
that's done you don't buy that's what
needs to happen
um or yeah you need to go back to
Maryland and you need to spend the money
you would have spent on the house on
airline tickets to come see your boy or
more often he needs his mama well more
than he needs a stretched thin barely
hanging on barely sober mom coming to
see him
yeah yeah it's hard for me to imagine
going back to using I mean August will
be 10 years that I've been clean and
sober so proud of you it's awesome thank
you thank you thank you yeah it's hard
for me to imagine going back there yeah
but the thing is you don't want to
there's no point in creating all these
stress points that's what John's saying
about you being thin yeah
yeah yeah and you're right yeah somebody
needs to give up something here
to get a more sane life situation and
only then do you make the decision to
buy but no cementing the separated
marriage by you buying a house
uh for six years no no yeah I would make
a very clear within 90 days within 180
days we are living together some way or
another right what's that look like you
may have to deal with an ugly reality
an ugly reality where he says I'm not
leaving
and then y'all are going to have some
hard choices to make and some hard
decisions to make but just pretending
that those hard decisions don't have to
be made is just making you both crazier
and crazier and crazier yeah
and I love I love how you want to be
there with your son and I think that
that is it is important
um and there's other ways to accomplish
it rather than buying a house and uh in
a town because you haven't been able to
find a rental but I don't even want you
buying a real I don't even want you
finding a rental I want you guys to
solve for how we're going to be together
and how we're going to serve the 12 year
old and I think it's important Dave
people call my show all the time asking
about you know what do I do how do I
deal with an anxious kid or how do I
deal with a kid that's struggling
depression the number one answer I'm
always going to tell parents
you go get well because your kids are
absorbing that stuff you go take care of
you make sure you're whole and then
Circle back and start trying to solve
your kid it almost always not always but
almost always begins to lift that child
up in mom and dad are whole not a 12
year old 12 year old on the planet that
doesn't look at this marriage situation
and go oh right this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the Dr
John deloney show is my co-host today
all about relationships mental Wellness
boundaries crazy family members all that
stuff yeah it's all in there and uh so
and and we all have crazy family members
if you think you don't that means it's
you
just keep that in mind all right that's
how we know this all right so but and I
John lately I've been getting
like in the last week I've gotten five
emails
from prominent
people that I am friends with
asking me if the banks are going to
collapse
um
and these are people that I would have
thought
wouldn't have thought that all but one
man he pretty much believes all the
conspiracy theories but yeah but the uh
or the world's coming to an end or
whatever and it's all Joe Biden's fault
and all that kind of stuff right so but
but the other guys are like I'm like
you're really
really uh and I have to send them a nice
email back
assuring them
that were okay and Warren Buffett comes
out this week and says uh
Berkshire Hathaway Berkshire Hathaway
his company's annual meeting he
suggested fear is contagious and
consumers fears about the safety of
their banking institutions are making it
hard to respond to the crisis
effectively because the people in the
banking world and in the government have
done such a poor job of messaging what's
really going on that was Buffett's point
and it's it's causing fear to be
contagious now we ran into I think
during
um covid that fear was more contagious
than covet was correct and more
contagious than the fear was the
financial incentive for media companies
to spread fear
that is their that's how they get paid
and so I I think what he I think he's
calling out something that's really
important we're herd animals so fear is
contagious that's how we've survived as
a species if somebody starts running we
all just start running with them right
but if you have an entire banking
industry an entire media industry an
entire all everybody telling you run run
all the time I went out the back door
there was five deer standing there and
uh one of them got spooked and the other
four are going we're running but why are
we running why are we running
we don't think we're sophisticated Dave
our brains are operating at that level
when we are scared we're running but I
don't know why I don't know why we're
running why are we pulling up
everything's going to go listen we're
going to die I think he calls something
out important here it used to be up
until very recently you had to get in
your car and drive down and look at your
banker and say I want to take all my
money out and they would say that's dumb
and they could calm you down now I can
just go online in the with the glow and
pull it all out and so he is right there
is this moment now when we can all be
stupid and there's no guard rails on our
stupidity yeah right you know and so I I
I'm calling Dave I I'm almost begging
there has to be some group of people
that are running the news stations that
have to have a moment of conscience to
say we've got to stop and I know it
sells tickets I get it but we've got to
come up with another way than just
trying to get people to panic because
it's going to run us all off a cliff
it just is hit the fair porn the fear
off the media is driving this and fear
is contagious so other than getting the
media to behave because I still think
they're probably going to yell at us
that we're all going to die of a tornado
by Nightfall but um you're gonna die
it's just God it's hilarious I'm gonna
yeah probably not
um probably not gonna die I'm you know
this and if I do guess what I'm dead
whatever yeah but um go I'm going with
this I'm sticking with it so you know
the if the media is not going to turn
off the fair porn
fear is contagious correct how do we
what are some things that the average
the typical person can do
to calm and go wait a minute
so uh I I think I've talked about this
with you privately
um when I was in 2008 2009 2010 when the
the other banking crisis happened and I
was just anxious out of my mind I sat
down with a guy who's Works in banking
and I just hammering him hammering him
and he got me to a point the facts are
your friends facts your friends here's
what he said he said John if you take
all of your money out of the bank and
all of the banks implode your money is
absolutely worthless and his quote was
so fantastic he said your neighbor will
be coming over to hunt you for your
water it's a different ball game so the
idea that you're going to save yourself
by doing a thing is false that's that's
it's not truthful it's not a fact so the
greatest thing you can do is leave your
stuff alone leave your stuff alone and
that's just again looking at facts I
think I think the the answer to if is
fear contagious how do you
keep from Catching it
um one is you just take them turn off
everything yeah turn off the stupid
television but the the news channels but
the uh the second thing is facts are
your friends right okay and everything
that's on the internet is not a fact
correct
um everything that's on the internet is
not true Abraham Lincoln said that okay
so um you know that's uh you know so you
know that these things so just because
your conspiracy
uh Theory friend Rachel Cruz
says that this is going to occur does
not mean that it's actually going to
occur as a matter of fact it's a high
probability if you're conspiracy friends
thinking it's going to happen
that they're wrong correct very high
probability correct and play taking the
facts of your friends take it all the
way out you have twenty five thousand
dollars in cash in in a box and the U.S
banking system implodes
that will be good for kindling right I
mean kenneling yeah you can start a
firework you can start a firework what
are you actually going to do yeah right
exactly and so hang in there there's a
whole bunch of other people that have
way more money that have a vested
interest in this thing working out so be
still and be slow and turn turn The the
chaos off your T off your devices
um so so number one is stop your inputs
uh whether they be conspiracy theories
or media channels this number two is sit
down and calmly think about and even
write down what the real facts of the
situation are not what the rumors or the
emotions are
because the feelings will lie to you
right and you have a supernatural
ability to do this Dave I don't I have
to call a friend that I trust and say
hey man I'm spun up on this can you give
me some wisdom that's what my buddies
are doing to me I guess and I've got any
other human abilities
oh there's another bank failed are we
going no we're not it's just a bad bank
I mean
and you know and there's some stupid
people in the banking World here's the
thing
I have observed this and here's a fact
for you out there if you're worried if
you are got a little of this uh you
caught this contagious fear bug okay
here's a fact for you I've noticed that
you're gonna love this from higher
education
um
it Financial downturns run on this
Rhythm and this cycle
when the current crop of mbas
gets to 38 years old
and has no memory of the last stupid
stuff they repeat it and calls the next
one correct
and so there's a rhythm they don't have
any institutional memory because they
don't have a memory they weren't there
when we survived 2008 so now here we are
eight years later you know and six years
later and now we're on that Rhythm the
people that didn't okay I survived 2008
I made a lot of money in 2008 when
everything turned down because I bought
a lot of stuff while it was down real
estate and
um mutual funds both were down it was a
great buying opportunity and everything
I bought in those days has doubled and
so yeah I made a ton of money yeah and
so my institutional memory is long
because I'm old right and but but you
know the the people making stupid butt
decisions like loaning people money to
buy a house who are broke
when broke people buy houses and we sell
them millions of them you're gonna break
the economy correct because they can't
pay the bill stupid correct you know but
when you get a group of people who don't
remember that from 2008 they're gonna do
it again
because that new crop of mbas turns 38
and they don't remember the last one
they replicate the problems and that's a
lot of what you're seeing with these
Bankers right now they're stupid but
horrible practices in a particular bank
because they don't because a 38 year old
that doesn't remember 2008.
wasn't functioning in their role in 2008
is now making the similar mistakes and
that's what's happening so you're okay
we're okay people it's a normal rhythm
of dumb butt mbas this is a Ramsey Show
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author host of
the Dr John deloney show is a podcast on
the Ramsey networks make sure you check
that out he's my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five angels with us in Des
Moines hi Angel how are you
are you guys better than we deserve
what's up
um so um I love your plan by the way I I
don't have five Financial Peace
University but I have been following the
steps I started in September
um and I got my
um thousand dollar emergency fund and
I've actually been able to pay 25 000
off in the last eight months of debt way
to go that's awesome Angel yes yes um 10
000 of it was
um a gift my grandpa passed away and he
left each of his grandkids ten thousand
dollars and
I decided though even though it wasn't
fun and it wasn't something super
meaningful I decided to put just throw
all that at my debt and I knew my
grandpa my grandpa hated debt so he he's
smart he's smiling then how can we help
today
um yeah so my uh my car is paid off I
drive a Acadia and we still have a
little bit of my husband's truck loan so
we only have one car payment I'm about
ready to pay off my last credit card and
then we have a small personal loan and
the rest of my husband's truck and
unfortunately this past Sunday we got
caught in a hail storm and it really
bangs up my car my windshield's cracked
shattered and tons of hail damage and so
we've taken it to the adjuster and to
insurance and all that we haven't
actually heard back yet but he wants me
to get a new car
who the adjuster
sorry I forgot to say my husband my
husband my husband I have to get another
car probably aren't you well no it's
drivable oh okay but you think you think
the hails totaled it because it was
crappy anyway right
I'm 14 I'm
I mean what's it worth
I'm honestly I'm not exactly sure you
find out before you're starting
negotiating with an adjuster right right
I
I probably
worth about ten thousand okay if they
total it then they're going to give you
a check for ten thousand why would you
need a loan it will
wants it to be like a Tahoe or you know
something we have three kids yeah but
you're broke and getting out of debt
where did he I thought no so now I
understand why you said I paid off all
the debt I did this I did that because
he's sitting on the sidelines not
involved in this plan
no he's not no he's not he's a whiner
it's nice like nice things but only when
I can afford them that's the difference
in a child a grown-up
yes yes and you've been defending him
for a long time haven't you
well and here's like I don't want to put
all
credit cards at like you're the only
reason you're getting out
you remember that foot you put down you
remember that when you remember that
time when you put your foot down
yeah okay you need to use that exact
same motion again
we're not taking out a loan to get a
Tahoe
yeah and here's another one when you put
your foot down you and I are going to
sit down and get on the same page on
money
I'm not gonna drag you I'm not your
mother
I need a man walking beside me not a
little boy who wants to buy things he
can't afford I've got to have some
teamwork going here I feel like I'm
dragging you around behind the car
yeah that's your other foot going down
and if you guys can't get on the same
page spend a little money on some
marriage counseling
yeah because here's my promise if you're
not on the same page here there are
other things in your house that you're
not on the same page for true or false
I'm true true guaranteed true yeah
so the the thing is is when you can
agree on your money you've agreed on
your life that's how John knows that
because your money always flows away
from your fears and towards your dreams
and so you have to agree on your dreams
and agree on your fears and agree on a
process that the principles of money
that are going to get us there the
principle and so you know the when we're
not in agreement on those things then
you know we're not in agreement on
hardly anything it comes it because the
money disagreement shows up in all the
other conversations
right yeah listen your marriage is going
to get like five million times better
when you guys are in agreement on what
you're doing with money because it's
gonna it's gonna filter into all these
other areas and I don't buy the argument
for one single second
that just because you have three kids
means you have to buy a land tank by the
way I love Tahoes I love them they're
incredible cars you cannot afford them
you can't afford one well if you can
find one for ten thousand that's okay
right or if you want to be a gangster
drive your car that's drivable that
looks ridiculous and looks awful drive
it around yeah until you've paid off
your debts well this is what I
what I if you think it's a good an idea
but obviously I need a new windshield
but other than that the dents are just
like cosmetic I would like to take
whatever money we get from insurance
whether it's totaled or just
um whatever it needs to get fixed I want
to take after I buy a windshield I just
want to take that money and throw it at
our debt what how much debt have you got
left
um so like I I have two thousand dollars
left and with my snowballing I I will be
able to pay that two thousand dollar
credit card off this month okay not not
counting this okay how much other debt
have you got how much
truck 15.
oh no no no that was what it was in
September truck is 12. and then
um our personal loan which this is this
has been years and years of us going
into debt and then getting out of debt
so this personal loan was through our
bank to help us pay off debt and we said
we never get how much credit card it's
12. okay she got 12 on the truck 12 on
that and you're getting 10. what's your
household income
household income I am self-employed I
I'm a I own a salon so mine what's your
household income I'm sorry
a month give or take his as consistent
mine is a little different so full stop
if you are if you two are actually on
the same page
you could drive this beat up car for
just a couple of few months
Before Christmas you would be 100 debt
free
and then you would save up and buy a
better car before Christmas but you've
got to be on the same page for that to
occur
and yeah you the your momentum the speed
at which you're doing this has slowed
down by your lack of agreement
oh I know so it's what I do 100 percent
yeah yeah so if you guys can sit down
and get on the same page I'm with John
I'd go gangster but if you're gonna have
to drag him down the street with this
thing I'm probably going to go ahead and
get a car because it's going to take a
while
but if you can go gangster for four
months and you guys get on beans and
rice you can with ten thousand dollars
towards your twenty four thousand
dollars worth of debt uh that only
leaves 14 you make eight a month we're
gonna knock that out really fast
yeah but you're gonna have to be on the
same page and say we're not going out to
eat and you have been we're not going on
vacation and he has one planned this
summer and so on and he can't buy you a
Tahoe at Christmas and think he's doing
you a favor with a loan right ever again
no more we're done
so yeah if you guys can get on the same
page that would be what we would do at
the Ramsey house but the the point being
all of this other stuff's going to fall
in line all this money stuff and all
this debt stuff and it's going to March
right down the street really really fast
once the two of you are on the same page
but you're pulling against each other
right now you're using all your energy
doing that and uh you really need to sit
down and do this so I'm going to give
you a Financial Peace University the
only thing that is required if I give it
to you for free is you have to make him
go through it with you
and I'll convince him because it's what
I've done for 10 million people this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author there's
my co-host today phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so John it's been about a year
since own your past change your future
came out and was the number one
bestseller that's right it's um it is
out and
since it published I've gotten tons of
calls from people asking for private
counseling sessions and I can't meet
with 101 with everybody it's not
possible and that's why we wrote the
book the book is really just you and me
sitting across a table
um eating and having a meal and trying
to figure out what we're going to do
next right so it's practical advice and
encouragement on topics like
relationship overcoming past hurt
healing from traumas you may not even
know you experienced and as you read
through each section I'll show you how
to learn from what happened in your past
so you can start focusing on what it
means to live well and Dave this is
awesome one of my favorite things is
when you decide to sell our books for
cheap and we're included uh this is the
first time ever that own your past
change your future is a part of the ten
dollar sale so all the best sellers on
your past change your future redefining
anxiety plus all the questions for
humans conversation cards at our 10
bucks just ten dollars and Dave I
checked in with the guys yesterday and
they're like dude questions for humans
are flying out of the building yeah yeah
we can't keep them um but on your passes
uh change your future is ten dollars for
the first time ever so get your copy of
own your past change your future today
or any second edition questions for
humans cards for 10 bucks at
ramseysolutions.com check it out check
it out phone number here triple eight
eight two five five two two five a Joyce
is in Philadelphia hi Joyce welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi Dave uh good afternoon to you and
John you too
I've been doing the baby steps since
uh before the worst thing I guess
um happily retired at 62 married
um children grown out of the house half
is paid for we have no debt
my husband is very uh mechanically
electronically like he's like a wizard
when it comes to like uh anything that's
electrical
so we cut the cord with our internet and
wireless provider and they they sent our
last bill to collection and I've never
gotten a collection letter and I want to
tell them
can you guess who it is it's in
Philadelphia it starts with a C I want
to tell them to go pound band their
service was not that bad
but breaking up with
all right it's Comcast I have a file on
breaking up with Comcast oh there are
entire websites devoted to breaking up
with Comcast
there are classes taught on breaking up
on how to do it there's probably in some
University near you a dollar degree on
how to break up with Comcast how much is
the debt Joyce
oh
it's 245 dollars pay it Joyce uh Joyce
pay can I ask you how much how close are
you to an actual stroke
well shouldn't I at least like calling
off with him half Joyce your soul is
worth more than 200.
like I know it's delicious at night yeah
you're trying to convince the devil that
he's not insane
and the devil's insane you're trying to
convince Comcast that they have bad
business practices is the same thing
shoot I I thought well what if it goes
to like are they going to ruin my credit
just pay them think about this you wake
up tomorrow and you don't ever think
about it again you're the only person on
the planet that cares about this 245
dollars
nobody over there at Comcast cares at
all not one second of their life they
don't care you're dying that's a slow
sad Comcast he death right now you would
spend 400 on a great massage at a resort
Hey listen I understand I'm I'm a
redneck hillbilly and we carry grudges
generationally so I choose
I choose some things to fight to the
death uh 245 dollars with Comcast it's a
it's a it's a it is a never-ending
whirly dervish I I whirling dervish I I
would not I would
write the check and be done with it
don't worry about the fact going to
collections doesn't matter you're not
borrowing money anyway and you're not
dealing with them ever again and believe
me they just lost more than 245 dollars
in the last uh minute and a half because
22 million dollar 22 million people
heard this conversation most of which
are nodding in agreement so you know
it's just
um what a horrible there I mean they
have a really bad I didn't know I didn't
know it's like iconic it really is I
mean there are websites devoted to how
bad they are it's they're just their
worst
yeah I mean when I was a kid it was a
mall Bale
did you ever hear that oh Mom no I was
born in the age of electricity what is
Mom that was the phone company oh okay
Ma Belle were they terrible to break up
with well they were the only ones
there was nowhere else to go tin cans
and strings were your only other option
or a possible Morse code wire but yeah
you can send a wire but yeah no I mean
it was yeah you're stuck with it and uh
it's the reason that there was a
monopoly breakup of the Bell Telephone
company named after Alexander Graham
Bell who invented it and so on so yeah
it was the Monopoly created horrible
service and we got the same thing here
so anyway Hey listen I remember I had a
medical bill I remember I'm on record
because they said I'm recording this I
said is this all I will ever have to pay
you if I pay you cash and they said yes
I said do you promise it's a point that
my wife was like John stop you asked
like five times and then I got a bill
for 170 bucks that was it I got so mad I
said I'm never paying this and that 170
turned into more and turned into more
and then I find out my wife paid it and
I got so mad but then I just was able to
sleep I stopped getting the bill it's
fine so I gotta have one we're doing
what's through stupid tax hour right now
yeah so my buddy this rented a car and
um I won't say the city but it was in a
foreign country and some cities that are
highly populated now you have to have a
a special sticker to go in the inner
city you pay extra to be able to drive
in the more congested areas and if you
drive in one of those more congested
areas without it they have cameras that
will take your picture without the
sticker and they will send you a bill
for every time you went down that street
so my buddies like driving a rental car
and he's like oh I'm going in there
anyway forget it I'm rules don't apply
to me so he drives down the street drops
his wife off at a shop and drives around
the block six times oh excellent six
tickets
for 50 bucks
300 right and didn't want to pay it and
uh by the time he finally got around to
paying it it kept doubling and it was
like four thousand dollars yeah
there's a warrant out for his arrest in
that country if he doesn't do that he
showed them good job yeah that's just
yeah that's drove around the I mean he
not only got the ticket he drove around
the same block and kept getting the same
camera six times
best part of the story yeah so we all
have done stuff like this
um you know and uh there's
you know I don't know if you actually
owe the 245 Joyce you probably don't but
it's you're going to spend
eight thousand dollars worth of worry
and man hours and stress trying to find
someone that cares and that is competent
all in the same body that works at
Comcast these three things together
don't come up much
they just don't come up much they care
they're competent and they work at
Comcast all at the same time they don't
come up much so they call them chances
yeah they're a unicorn the chances of
finding this are fairly low I would just
pay it and move on
I hate it it makes me mad too it's not
right it's morally wrong that's why
we're trashing them
but yeah you're stuck you're stuck kiddo
wow
uh yeah you got to clean these things up
and uh these things have a high rate of
Resurrection has less parrot says on
other things if you don't fix them they
just keep coming back to life like my
buddy going around the block same deal
that's the funniest one this there's the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting to the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book own your
past change your future is my co-host
today here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Megan is in
Dallas Hi Megan how are you
I'm will how are you
better than I deserve what's up
well first of all I'm just so grateful
that you took my call today
um so my question is I have got three
kids and uh 26 20 and 16. and I want to
know how to break the cycle with them
and teach them about money that was
never taught to my husband or I
so one time the coolest part about going
back to grad school as an old man was I
had to do an internship again
and I interned under this guy one of the
internships I had to do was under a guy
named Michael Gomez Dr Gomez and one day
we were working with uh kids who had
experienced some pretty significant
trauma and we were walking from one room
to the next and one of the the young
little boys we had talked to
um had some really awful things to say
about women
and I asked Dr Gomez as we were walking
from one room to the next I said wow
what are you supposed to tell what are
you supposed to say to little boys to
get them to respect women to make them
respect women and he looked at me and he
said you can tell them anything you want
but if you want to them to respect women
just know they're going to watch you
so they're going to he went on to say
like tip the waitress really well and
take care of your wife and your sister
and treat them with dignity and respect
they're going to watch you and so the
greatest way you can teach your kids how
to break the cycle is more of caught
than taught manage your money really
well and invite them into budget
conversations right okay that would
apply to the 16 year old but all of
these are old kids
yeah 20 and 26 is not exactly two and
four so when you say you break the cycle
is it a cycle that you continued
yeah so it's interesting I read Rachel's
book a couple years ago just about the
psychology of like how you grew up
financially and my husband and I grew up
in very different homes but the
psychology of it was very much the same
um he grew up in a very wealthy family I
grew up in a middle class family and but
neither one of our families like our
parents ever talked to us about money so
when we did get married we did start our
life together we really had zero clue as
to what we were doing we bought a house
we moved from California to Texas bought
a house just based on my husband's
credit score
um and a few years after getting here I
found my faith and heard the Lord tell
me to sit on my hands because I was the
main main provider
um to help uh so anyway long story short
we did end up foreclosing on our house
um we did file bankruptcy to try to save
the house again we had no idea just
didn't know any better and now we're
fast forward that was back in 2005 so
now we're here and we still have a
little bit of debt but it's it's
realistically small okay you're only the
only thing you can do with the 20 and
the 26 year old
does a 20 year old live with you
she does for how much longer
um I'm going to assume she's going to be
with us for at least another year she's
about to be a junior in college
okay so while she's in college she's
going to stay with you and are you guys
helping her with college
yes we have actually taken out loans for
both her and her sister so the 26 year
old and the 20 year old we have college
loans for okay
um well I think I would sit down with a
16 and the 20 year old and just go guys
um Dad and I are learning some new
things about money that we didn't know
before
and we weren't very good at it and so we
didn't teach you when you were young
about money but as we are learning about
these things as long as you are under
our roof you're going to learn about
them
because that's going to be good for you
as adults that's the 16 and the 20 year
old in other words as long as they're
you're writing checks for them you have
a certain level of power there that you
would exert but um but it starts with an
apology of I'll let you down I didn't
tell you because I didn't know and now
we're learning these new things we've
been through a bankruptcy in a
foreclosure and now we're learning to be
on a budget to live on less we make to
not use debt we're not using credit
cards we're using debit cards we don't
borrow money for anything we save up and
pay and we're always generous and these
are things we're learning in financial
peace and
um uh you know have you and your husband
been through Financial Peace University
yet
no okay we have not if I put you through
it will you take the 16 and the 20 year
old through with you
absolutely okay these are the things I
wish I had taught you I'm sorry I didn't
but they are going to apply to you as
long as you're under our roof going
forward so you need to know because it's
my job to do my best I can to help you
catch up and learn this stuff before you
leave my care
yeah but do you realize you hear what
Dave said because what he said is very
very important you are leading with I
screwed this up not here's what you all
need to know yeah you're leading with it
we've definitely have come from that
place with our kids and just saying you
know and letting you know like hey it's
kind of the way I did it on other issues
was because I I you know I got good news
and I got bad news the the good news is
is that we realize we screwed all this
up and I'm sorry uh the bad news is your
life's getting ready to change because
I'm fixing this yeah 100 and I think if
you're a good parent you'll do that
several times on several issues yes
there's a 26 year old you don't have any
power with at all
no the most difficult stage of parenting
is when they are no longer under your
control and you have to watch them as
quasi adults do stupid butt stuff
it's very difficult so the only Power
you have with a grown
uh child which is an oxymoron um but the
only Power you have with them is
persuasion
and so how would you you had you
probably have friends that have a 26
year old
and so if your friend had a 26 year old
and you wanted to convince them how
would you talk to them well you wouldn't
use your mom voice
your dad voice you would use persuasion
and you would talk about the time that
you messed up but how I learned more and
my life is better now and we're going
through this class called Financial
Peace and gosh man if I was 26 it'd be
the thing I'd want to do because now I
wish I had done it I wish I'd known it
then and this is how you talk to your
friends 26 year old is persuasion
language not uh preaching language or
shame language or all the history of the
family language it would just simply be
persuasion on this subject
okay so if I'm talking to Rachel Cruz
that's the only option I've got
but you've got a relationship too right
yeah but I mean it's a persuasion based
out of relationship but it's not going
to be a debt because your dad said so
right or you should do this to honor
your dad that doesn't work no
um I would also say this
that 26 year old lived in that house
where y'all went through bankruptcy and
tried to save the house that 26 year old
lived through hell
and I think there's something powerful
about a mom and a dad sitting at a table
saying we brought you through the
darkest of the dark and we're sorry yeah
here we are we love you and and so we're
going to give you two Financial Peace
universities one for the 26 year old and
one for the other four of you hang on
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
their wash and guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 percent off selected
products visit blinds.com today for more
info
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you like this show we'd
appreciate your help you can subscribe
or follow on the podcast or YouTube
channel that you're doing this you can
share the show sharing the link or click
the share button if the way you're
listening or viewing the show allows you
to you can share the show just by
telling people I listen to it on talk
radio I follow it on TBN wherever it is
you're watching to tell people to watch
listen and join us if you'll help us
spread the word it really helps we
really do appreciate it and of course
you can leave a five star review one
Stars aren't helpful mama said if you
had anything nice to say don't say
anything at all just move along
just move along if you hate something
why are you listening that's just weird
it's a certain kind of pathology that is
I hadn't thought about that if you hate
this show don't listen to it there's
certain kinds of music that I'm not a
fan of as much as others I don't listen
to that station
why is that hard the way you said that
was like so profound why is that hard I
don't know
a friend of mine gave me a book the
other day and it absolutely sucked
I will not read that author again ever
and he's a huge fan of this author but
he was just wrong but here's the thing
I've had several conversations with you
in the last week not one time have you
come to tell me
I you should never read this book I did
not I did not bring it up no what time I
don't understand that is a certain kind
of pathology like so the and the one
that really tickles me that I'll just
while we're doing it this is funny okay
so I haven't looked in a while but Total
Money Makeover is getting ready to
celebrate his 20th anniversary and uh
We've sold a little over 10 million
totally makeover books and on Amazon
there is something like I don't know 30
000 reviews okay and it's a 4.8 or 9 out
of five stars right
what
prompts someone
in that situation it would never occur
to me I mean I I like I'm a huge uh Brad
Thor fan okay Brad Thor's a fiction
writer he's a friend of mine who writes
all these wonderful CIA novels and all
this stuff and uh assassins and all the
you know shoot em ups I love it it's fun
and even if I didn't like that book I
read that I didn't like I'm not going to
go on Amazon and look and go it has 4.9
stars but me I'm after 25
000 other people have established that
it is a 4.9 I'm going to leave a one
I I don't get that I don't have I don't
have time for that well I don't get that
you're that wrong and still feel like
you need to say so I know but I don't
have enough time to go to the bathroom
in the day but my days are so full who
has time to be like hold on hold on kids
hold on hold on we gotta get one star
life stop talking I have to go tell the
world this guy's book sucks yeah I
really well yeah this radio show this
podcast show so there you go there's our
little rant but yeah it's just be nice
it's interesting to me
and I think you know we've been talking
about it a lot
um in a couple different settings we
were with Mike Rowe the other night
we're talking about that this this
little box that um
people carry around in their hand that
it's like a little magic wand you push
buttons on it and stuff happens
like you can push one button and stuff
will be on your porch the next day food
shows up the food shows up magically
it's like crazy and toilet paper right
there we live in Hogwarts now exactly we
do
it's a little magic wand box and it
gives you great power you can you can
access the entire breadth of knowledge
of the human race off of this little box
and uh through this weird thing called
Google
and you know and it's just it's very
interesting how much power that gives
you and I think because people have been
walking around for decades with this
great power in their hands that they
think their opinion matters
basement nobody needs to know what you
think here okay we're just gonna sit
here for a second here's what I don't
understand James is like please take a
call please take a call no no
we're gone we're down the rabbit hole
now buddy listen
you have a bunch of experience in
finance you've got academic credentials
you've got a lifetime of personal
experience and of working with other
people
I don't understand how I can ask you a
question and you give me an answer and
my first thought is well that guy's an
idiot
I I'm not gonna I don't want to be that
guy yeah I've got two phds two phds I
don't want to argue with you people are
like oh that's stupid I don't know a lot
a lot but I know those two
things right
in counseling yes if Andrew huberman
says uh actually dopamine works like
this my first instinct isn't to go that
guy's an idiot no I'm wrong or if I'm
not I've got to really dig and improve
why exactly exactly that's what I don't
I don't understand I think it has to do
with the arrogance of the magic wand
and then you may be onto something it's
given it's given too much agency too
much power the sense of I control my own
everything and it's a self-importance
there's an entitlement that goes with it
it's it's I think it's the magic wand I
really do all right Nicole Is With Us in
Atlanta
help us help James Nicole help us help
James what's up okay so
um my husband and I are trying to figure
out on what we should do with some money
um we have about 40
000 45
000 we're looking at and we don't know
if we should invest it put it towards
our house so our house is our only debt
that we have we have no cars
uh 170 but we have a very low interest
rate and what's your what's your
household income
um about uh 90 100 000 excellent and how
old are you two
um I am 34 and he is 31. okay what is
the goal here to make sure we maximize
low interest rates or that we build
wealth
only on we just want to keep building
both of us contribute to a Roth outside
of our country I wasn't asking that I
wasn't asking about your Investments I'm
asking so what is your goal is your goal
to I want to look like everyone else or
I want to build wealth as fast
we just want to build wealth and so
here's the deal we ten thousand
millionaires
that we studied
nine out of ten of them were first
generation Rich meaning they did not
inherit their money 89 okay
the number of them out of ten thousand
that we interviewed this said
I didn't pay off a low interest mortgage
and instead invested the money in that
was in the bank into mutual funds and
became wealthy doing that
was very close to zero
the vast majority of them said we paid
off our mortgage as fast as we could
regardless of the interest rate because
then when we don't have any payments
house payment included we can build
wealth Uber fast
and that's what most of them did that's
the data
okay not someone's opinion that's a
actual data all right in other words the
so the answer is the vast majority of
millionaires in America today by far I'm
not even a close second would pay off
the house as fast as they could I know
that because that's what they did
okay now here's my opinion if I'm you
and I owe 170 Grand I'm gonna put 40
that 40 Grand down on the house and oh
130 and I'm gonna sit with my spouse and
we are going to make a game plan to go
gangbusters and knock the rest of this
out as soon as possible four years you
should be your pal thousand four years
and I would try to do it too just
because I you can't do it I have a
problem yeah yeah we don't need to go
that hard I know it's okay baby step
five or baby step four five and six your
intent intentional not intense not
intense and so that's where we are here
if you're out of debt you have your
emergency fund other than your house
you're out of debt you have your
emergency fund in place you're putting
15 of your income away for retirement
throwing everything else at the mortgage
in your case making 100 Grand you could
be debt free in around four years house
and everything if you throw this 40 at
it that's following the millionaire path
that's how I answer the question it's
not what my opinion is it's what the
data tells me most people that built
wealth did if the data tells me most
people that built wealth wear black
shirts then John and I would both we
would be watch shirts so we would get
there you know I mean what's the data
tell me the behaviors of the people I
want to be like that have the success in
the area if the data says you want to be
married 50 years here's how you treat
your spouse that's how you treat your
spouse it's really not rocket science
and so it's a really really good
question on your part thank you for
asking it but the culture normal people
who are broke would say no you don't
want to get rid of that mortgage you
want to keep it around because it's so
such a blessing
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us triple
eight eight two five five two two five
well if you listen to the show long
enough you can piece together uh the
things we talk about
and I think there's like
um I don't know how many YouTube clips
we have uh it would be probably close to
ten thousand on our page including all
the nine million debt-free screams but
if you watched you all of the 9 000
YouTube clips you could probably figure
out everything we teach or you
and the fastest way and the most
effective way and that's take Financial
Peace University
I can get all your stuff for free you
can get all my stuff for free before I
was on the air it's called common sense
[Laughter]
it's always been free it's just not
always been common you know so if you
really want to do this stuff the right
way the quickest easiest way the best
path that I know is Financial Peace
University and our personalities
including one Dr John deloney are all
coordinating classes so Ken Coleman Dr
John deloney Eddie Cullen uh Rachel Cruz
George Campbell and Jade is leading the
way and I'm getting killed here guys
you're getting killed I'm getting killed
well Jade and Rachel are crushing me
yeah well I need your help
with the guy with two phds which is two
more than all the rest of them put
together saying yes are they smarter
than me yes are they prettier than yeah
all those things are true definitely
yeah but listen
I need your help I'm crying out America
help me out here we got all the we got
personality classes if you want to go
through the classes with a personality
being your coordinator the classes are
still the videos but the important part
is the relationships with the
coordinator and the rest of the group
you're doing that virtual in this case
sometimes it's in person at your local
church but you can join any of these
classes now Jade and Rachel's class do
have a disadvantage in that they've
already started correct now you can jump
in because this first week and catch up
but uh in my classes during lunch break
so it's for between 12 and 1 you can
take it when you're in uh where you're
working you can step out in the car take
it whatever and kins and I think
Georgia's are in the evening time there
you go Financial Peace University at
ramseysolutions.com or just go to
fpu.com and sign up for one of these
coordinated classes with a Ramsey
personality and apparently we're trying
to help John out today this is the John
deloney Telethon section of the show
Dial 1-800 help no I'm kidding that's
not a real number all right Tim is in
Huntsville hey Kim Welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave and John thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
okay so my father-in-law has been living
on his own for about a year and a half
separated from his wife but not legally
yet
um and he about a month ago he got a new
job making more than us than my husband
and I combined
um but over the last month he's asked us
for money to kind of cover his
I guess but until he got paid
um and every time he asked my husband
from the money my husband can't say no
because he feels bad he's like that's
what we're supposed to do is help family
um but I think his father or I think my
father-in-law has kind of taken
advantage of the fact that he knows that
we have money
um because we just recently sold our
short-term rental
um and so
I guess I'm just kind of stuck because
this has nothing to do with your
father-in-law has everything to do with
your marriage
right well I tell him I told my husband
no but then I think it's his
relationship with his father because he
feels bad because of his situation I
know but when you tell him no you are
taking on the role of his mom
right so you sit down and say when you
do this you make me feel less than when
you do this I feel like you're slapping
me your wife in the face because I'm
your partner in this deal and you are
making a decision a solo decision in a
in a a commitment we made to make
decisions together that's different than
no I said no
well yeah that's true I haven't actually
said no the last couple times because I
figured he's he's trying to catch up on
his bills because he lost his previous
job so I haven't said no the last couple
of times I you know but I worry that
going in the future you know future that
it's gonna keep coming up because 100
chance yes y'all are a free bank for
your father-in-law no because your
husband needs to run down to Walmart
pick up a backbone on aisle three
no he's a very weak person he's a coward
well he looks at money differently we
grew up differently it doesn't matter no
he is not giving money to his father
because he's generous he's giving money
to his father because he's too weak to
tell him no
and I can tell by your answers that you
spend a lot of time defending him
yeah
you need to have a hard conversation in
your marriage
it's a marriage problem it's not your
father-in-law's fault your father-in-law
is doing what he does he's that kind of
guy he's a parasite
we would have to talk about but okay I
think the way you address it is you and
your husband come to agreement on the
way we're going to handle money and when
we're going to be generous and under
what circumstances we're going to be
generous and generosity is never a sign
of weakness it's always a sign of
strength
no one is actually generous from
weakness or always generous from
strength
and so right and so we come into this
conclusion we say Okay father-in-law has
an actual real need because even though
he's going to be making more money right
this second he doesn't have a dime until
his check comes in so we're gonna you
know we're gonna take him down the
grocery store and fill up his buggy and
we'll pay for it that's something we
could both agree to I would agree to
that as a matter of fact but he can't
say no
yes he can he's choosing not to he can
say no right he can say no well you have
gotten he has got his my father-in-law
has gotten his you know first and second
paycheck okay then it's over should be
over he makes more money than you do
this is stupid now
and if it's all if he's not calling you
anymore this is a great time because the
Smoke's cleared a little bit to go do a
post-mortem and take uh your husband out
to lunch and say look man what happened
last time that can't happen anymore we
have to be unified together on how we
spend money and how we take care of each
other
and here's something to keep in your
back pocket here's a sentence and I
didn't make this up this is
um from the mental health ether if you
will
choose guilt over resentment every time
every time because if you keep giving
him money and your husband keeps giving
him money even though like he's making
money he starts to the shame builds up
and what he's gonna over time he's gonna
hate his dad
and I don't want anybody to hate their
parents but to not hate your parents
sometimes you have to be a grown-up and
set boundaries that you follow
and so I'm going to choose to feel
guilty when I can't afford to go on this
Christmas that my mother-in-law is
demanding I go on not my mother-in-law
for real my mother-in-law's awesome but
I'm not I'm gonna choose guilt over I
can't go to that birthday party or I
can't afford to go to that wedding
because I'm in baby step two I'm going
to choose guilt over
borrowing money to go to a wedding and
hating everybody at the wedding the
whole time I'm there hating the bride
for inviting me that's on me it's about
boundaries should I just said no just
say no right and feel guilty of course
you're gonna feel guilty sorry I can't
make this one yeah
and so now so Kim here's the thing if
you and your husband can get on the same
page about generosity and about money
and about when we make decisions
together on these things or we don't go
forward you increase the probability of
your wealth building by 10x
the number of millionaires that we
interview that say we became
millionaires in spite of a constant
disagreement with my spouse about money
is almost zero
the number of millionaires that we
interview that say I work hand in glove
like a real team we're in complete
agreement on money the unity in our
marriage on money's unbelievable there's
a high correlation between those kinds
of statements and actual wealth has
obviously Common Sense would indicate
and by the way the byproduct is also an
incredible marriage so and those are the
things we need to work on you're not
going to fix your father-in-law that's
not your job this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
thank you for joining us Derek is in
Detroit hi Derek welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey it is an absolute honor to be
talking to you guys today I really
appreciate you taking my call you too
how can we help
all right well I'll cut right to the
chase end so Dave my life is kind of a
mess right now I mean it's it's crazy
um I'm trying to do your system here I'm
trying to do your method
um but right now I don't really know
where to start basically I'm 26 years
old I work as a mortgage loan officer
here in Detroit Michigan and if you know
anything about the mortgage industry
kind of tough right now at the beginning
industry yeah it's not what it used to
be
and my income has taken a hit safe to
say
and I've got about I would say 68 000 in
non-mortgage debt
and I also own my home on top of that
which is about a two hundred thousand
dollar mortgage so
you know I want this to be the year that
I start to really tackle this kind of
stuff but
um I'm going to kind of throw a
curveball in here and that curveball is
I am currently going through a divorce
oh no
it's tough It's you know things are
better now I will say that and you know
the process is underway and what's
happening is
I kind of want to sell the house and use
that to kind of jump start this process
and kind of alleviate some of the burden
because I'm finding that my income isn't
enough
I don't really have enough left over at
the end of the week to really
to do anything with it you know I'm kind
of scraping by here so I kind of want to
sell the house
but my soon to be ex-wife doesn't want
to sell the house
um she's out event that she wants to
keep it
I don't really know what to do maybe
this call is premature because you know
we're still waiting for the process and
everything I kind of just want to know
where to start and if I have any real
options here moving forward you have an
attorney yet
I do good okay
so here's
um what has to happen
whoever's going to keep the house if
it's either one of you has to refinance
it and get the other one off of the
mortgage
right because too often attorneys take
the lazy way out and for instance she
wants to keep the house and you say Okay
um how much is the by the way how much
is the house worth you owe 200 but
what's it worth
it's hopefully worth about 280 maybe
285. okay all right and so you probably
got after expenses if you sold it you
probably got 20 25 000 bucks a piece in
this right so if she's going to keep the
house she would give you credit for 25
000 or something else
or pay you 25 000 in cash one of the two
to buy out your half of the house in a
divorce and then some attorneys that are
lazy would tell you to quit to claim
deed the house to her
she bought out your half and you give
her the ownership
problem is you're still on the mortgage
and in the mortgage business you know
what that means next time you go to get
a mortgage you already have a mortgage
and it's going to be difficult and so
someday when you're remarried and have a
new life and you're moving along and
your ex-wife five years from now eight
years from now still has a mortgage with
your name on it you're screwed so we're
not going to do that
so here's here's your instructions to
your attorney
if she wants to keep the house she's
going to buy me out
of that my half and she's going to
refinance
otherwise we're going all the way before
the judge to force the sale of the house
okay just because she wants to keep it
doesn't mean she gets to keep it
does she make enough money to make the
payment on that mortgage
I don't think so
um I think that we've talked about it
and so she's delusional about the
results of this divorce in terms of
where she's going to end up financially
I'm I my big thing is I just want to
avoid conflict you know I'm not going to
you're going to get a divorce divorce is
conflict
right it seems to be the recurring theme
for me no it's the nature of the Beast I
mean you don't get to avoid it if you
avoid it it's going to come back up so
one way to avoid it is yeah sure I'll
just teach you the house honey and then
later on it's going to come back up like
I described to you a while ago remember
that part
oh yeah so if you avoid conflict and
don't deal with it it comes back up
later it has a high rate of Resurrection
I think I think it was Dave I think Dave
I think you're the one who who gave me
this analogy which I think is great the
moment somebody files for divorce
it no longer is about preserving a
marriage it's a business transaction
from this point forward
yeah this is just math and balance
sheets and legalities take emotions out
of it take drama out of it this is a
business 68 000 worth of debt it's you
know 80 000 gross probably fifty
thousand net worth of equity on this
property and it's uh and we're both on
the mortgage is there cars involved
I own my own car I have about a 12 000
loan on it and she leases her car so you
know they don't have your name on either
one your name's not on hers
you know what it might be yeah I might
be
it likely is same situation there
brother she doesn't pay the bill the car
will get repoed you can't go pick it up
and sell it it's called Grand Theft Auto
if you do
you have to force her name your name off
of these things so you know untangling
a marriage is legally and financially
and contractually very hard and by the
way the divorce decree does is not a
magic wand that well the judge said she
has to pay her bills now not if he's got
your name on it
the judge saying then the divorce decree
okay you get your car you get your car
but both your names are still on them
the divorce Probate Court does not
supersede contract law
and divorces in Probate Court so you're
you're not going to get I mean you get
your names off of these things as a part
of this deal or it's going to come back
to haunt you in every case and every
time you do this it's going to be a
point of conflict oh well
somebody wanted out of this and this is
the cost of getting out of it so let me
give you a baseline I want you to live
by okay it's a chapter in my new book
you have to choose reality
the reality is you're in a business
transaction that's going to be
uncomfortable for a season that's just
the way it's going to be you have a job
that you love
that has changed and you are not making
enough money to pay your bills that's
reality so you have to live out of that
reality and either take a second job for
a while until the mortgage industry
picks back up or take another job as a
different kind of lender you got to make
it some hard calls and not just sit in
the middle of this and stare off into
space and wonder what to do next what to
do next but there's something about
writing down reality here's all the
truths again we talked about earlier in
an earlier segment facts are your
friends here's the reality I am getting
divorced my wife has filed divorce on my
heart is broken my heart is broken and
I'm sad as I'll get out I need to
connect with a group of friends I am not
making enough money to pay my own bills
all those things have to come on a piece
of paper and then you can be about
solving what you can solve right I want
you to uh hang on the line here I'm
going to send you a copy of my buddy Ken
Coleman's paycheck to purpose I want you
to read that and ask yourself is there
something else I can do Beyond this
mortgage lending is there another Avenue
I want to take because this might be the
moment in your life to do that and I own
your past change your future give you a
copy of that one too both of them yeah
I'm sorry man I hate this for you listen
um I don't like conflict
is everyone
anyone who says they love conflict is
weird
or they have a really close conflict I
don't relish conflict but I do relish
the results
the cleanliness
the simplification of my life when I
engage in hard conversations now to
avoid having a worse conversation later
and I have learned to embrace Conflict
for that reason but it's not because I'm
like thrilled with the idea of pissing
people off for you know no that's not
what I'm trying to do that's not the
goal but I will do the hard conversation
but to get the long-term result that's
proper that's grown-up stuff correct and
uh but just I'm going to be in denial
now that that that's going to get you
burned so you got to get your name off
that car you got to get your name off
that mortgage and it may mean you sell
both of them and you force the sale of
both of them as a part of the divorce
decree oh well and Dave uh it's a it's a
common thing that we all do but I see it
especially in divorces when somebody
files for divorce they often look at
what the other person makes and they
divide that in half and they spend that
money in their mind and that's just not
how it works and so she might feel like
she's losing now because she wanted the
house and she wanted the card that's
just going to be part of this conflict
that they're heading into yeah exactly
wow
that puts us out with the Ramsey Show in
the books
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people
build wealth to work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and host of the Dr John deloney
show on Ramsay networks great podcast
just out there is my co-host today and
we'll be talking about your life and
your money the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Michelle's in Springfield Illinois hi
Michelle welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
well um I am on baby steps four five and
six I have two kids I've worked for this
particular company for 12 years I'm not
married yet engaged to my children's
father for a very long time
um anyway uh recently the company I work
for offered me one share
ownership
um and I guess my question is is this
something I should do
if it is something I could should
consider what what do I need to look for
um
and if it is something I should do
should I
pay how should I pay for it
uh have they given you a price
yes
um the price is uh seventy six thousand
dollars
and do you have seventy six thousand
I do okay that's good all right and um
so then I assume this is a small
business of some kind
um and so one share
doesn't matter and you know what matters
is how many other Shares are there
um
there's 110
shares
yes
okay
and you're gonna have one
yep just one just get my foot in the
door
the other uh 109 are owned by who
um uh currently
eight other people
um and they offered the same deal to
people total
okay
what's the gross revenues of this
company
um
I have that somewhere
I would have to
find that number are they trying to
expand the executive leadership are they
trying to do a cash raise by getting
their employees to put some money on the
table
service and for the people that are
aging out of ownership you know they
want to retire some new blood to
essentially fill their spots
so
is this company doing 20 million a year
profit
I
I don't I don't know okay well to start
with we need to put a value on your
share all right in order for your share
to be worth seventy six thousand dollars
if there's 110 other ones like it
um that's 76 million dollars and uh in
gross revenues or in I'm sorry in
profits
um and so your share uh then it would be
about a fourth of that would have to be
what the profit is to be to Value this
company for this company I have a 76
million dollar Prof value it would need
to have a 20 million dollar
um
uh net profit somewhere in that range
okay otherwise your share is overvalued
and I really smell
the loosey-goosey way this is handled is
that they stuck a wet finger in the air
instead of actually did evaluation I
think they just said oh let's see if we
can get some people to buy it at that
you know I don't really know that
there's some math behind this there
might be but you can well there they did
have um an independent accounting firm
provided
oh okay all right then all right then I
was wrong okay and so based on that your
one 110th is worth 76 000 according to
them okay now all of that to say if you
were to buy this share
here's the downside you're what's called
a minority shareholder
your vote does not count because a
couple of those guys get together that
hold all the shares and they make all
the decisions
okay so you have absolutely no power
over how the business is run whether it
is sold whether we can a product line
put a product line in place whether we
borrow 20 million dollars at the bank
tomorrow uh whether we fire key
employees you have absolutely no power
from this ownership position none
the same you've got the same you've got
today
point being they could destroy the value
of the company if they not prop they
probably wouldn't do that to themselves
on purpose but they could do it with
decisions that you don't agree with
and then your 76 000 is going to be
worth nothing so you're in a powerless
position so I do not ever personally buy
into minority shareholder positions I
want at least 51 percent ownership uh in
my case I don't even do Partnerships so
I would just buy the company if I was
doing it but
um
so but but in your case you are
powerless against bad decisions or
unethical decisions because you are not
just because you're an owner you don't
have any any
percentage of ownership they give you
power does that make sense
yes so that's a very very scary thing
the upside is obviously that if the
company continues to grow and it is
obviously done very well at some point
in the past if it continues to grow your
76 000 could become worth a lot more
later what are the buyout Provisions if
you wanted to leave
[Music]
that I would have to research okay
um yeah so I'm imagining imagine this
person you've been dating forever
decides ah I don't want to be married
and you end up moving across the country
and get a different job how do you
unload this thing yeah how do they value
your share and how do they buy it
that's very important because you do
want to get your 76 000 back
well well yes you would you would in
that situation I would
10 years before I did it's got a 10-year
vest or they have 10 years to pay you
back
10 years to pay me back don't do this
don't do this
you have no power
and you have two it's so ill liquid you
can't get your money out
no you're one one hundred we're one one
hundred and tenth that's a pretty low on
the totem pole it's almost like buying a
CD with no Guaranteed Rate on it well
and you can take your money out for 10
years yeah and uh no I I wouldn't do it
I would stay away from it it's not it's
not palatable to you it is not a benefit
they're trying to create a benefit and
it's not it's you're better off put your
76 000 mutual funds and just rock on
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is by
co-host our question of the day comes
from neighborly the Ramsey Show question
of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
neighborly is the place to find Reliable
help for your home entrusted local
businesses like Glass Doctor Mr
Appliance and Mr Handyman visit
neighborly.com today and find home
experts that are available to serve you
all right today's question comes from
Jerry in Florida Jerry writes my wife
and I are debt free besides our mortgage
and I'm having a tough time combating a
family member who happens to work in
well self-management oh geez this family
member believes that using credit cards
and paying them off is a great tool to
build credit this family also believes
that using a credit family member also
believes that using a credit card is
better than cash because of the rewards
different cards give you miles cash back
Etc
with this member working in finance they
are more informative than I am when it
comes to managing money but after
listening to you for so long I can't
wrap my head around what they're saying
as the best option to build wealth
what's the best way to have a discussion
with this family member that I can stop
feeling pressured
whoa
ah I love you and I don't agree with you
and we're not going to be able to be
around each other if you don't shut up
how's that
or or
hey man thank you so much I appreciate
that I I'm just not using credit cards
and I know there there's I've heard
there's some great things but I'm just
not into using them but I appreciate it
yeah that's it yeah you don't get a vote
yeah don't get a vote he's just a doob
he happens to be in your family but he's
a dupe yeah and most people have dupes
in their families and you just I have
family members that vote the wrong way
I'm not going to discuss politics with
them because they don't know how to vote
they're not good at it and let's let's
let's let's look at
um his family member
using credit cards and paying them off
is the way you build credit if you care
about credit then that's a thing and if
you think the credit is going to cause
you to Bill wealth which is an
interesting dichotomy because most
millionaires don't believe that correct
not little doob in the wealth management
business believes that but he's 26 and
has an MBA so he's correct I'm just
opting out of that system
if you want to build credit yeah but
building credit is not a method to build
wealth no it's a waste of yeah it's a
fun way unless you're wanting to build
wealth for the bank it's a fun way to
run around a circle and make other
people Rich
um can you can you get rewards from
using credit cards yes I have chosen in
my house with my family to opt out of a
system because my flights are not free
the person who pays for my flights is a
single mom who can't make her payments
who somebody said if you use this little
plastic card it'll get you till next
week and she's buying my flights and I
refuse to let the people in the margins
pay for
crap my family's doing I'm not I'm
opting out of that system the number of
millionaires in the largest study of
millionaires ever done this said they
made their money on cash back rewards
and airline miles is precisely zero zero
none none of them no millionaire ever
said I became wealthy with Airline Mouse
and it's just dumber and crud but it's
it's it's different I mean it's not
different it's people think they're
they're beating the system but also the
way those points are presented as though
the bank or the gas station is hooking
you up these flights are helping you out
because you're Bros now they're not
they're not your friend they're not your
friend but here you know the overall
answer how do you deal with the pressure
from Adobe family member is simply this
those convinced against their will are
of the same opinion still my grandmother
used to say so you're not going to be
able to argue with him enough to where
he quits being a doob because he is a
professional dude I mean he's just a
duper okay and so you can't talk to him
you can't talk him out of being who he
is you can't present enough information
that he's going to change his mind
there's not going to be an argument
about it and so just that so once you
realize you're not going to be able to
change him
he's not going to change you then the
best thing we can do if we want to
remain on good terms let's not talk
about the subject correct because
I'm just going to get pissed off at you
and let's think of the word pressure
pressure comes from two sides there's
got to be a bottom to it and it's got to
be compressed
I I don't allow people to provide
pressure put pressure on me because I
don't feel like my back's up against the
wall I'm not going to engage in the
conversation I'm going to walk away from
you right yeah the first time I had this
I had a guy that was a car dealer that
was a Christian
and he called up and uh called up a
friend of mine that was we had a mutual
friend a pastor and the Pastor said hey
so-and-so wants to meet with you because
he believes you know his brothers in
Christ that you all have an honest
disagreement he wants to have a
discussion with you about it well he's a
car dealer and he sells car leases
and I said well yeah I'll be happy to
meet with him but the net result of the
conversation when we're done is he's
going to go back to the office and Lease
cars and I'm going to turn on a micro
turn on a microphone and say if you
lease cars you're stupid
and we both love Jesus
and but I'm not he's not I'm not going
to talk him into not leasing cars and
he's not going to present any
information as much as I know about the
subject that's going to make me suddenly
believe leasing cars is a good idea
but I did this was early in my career
out of an effort of spirituality I
thought well I'll sit down with my
brother and we'll try to talk that was
just a complete waste of air
it's a complete waste of air because
there was nothing was going to change as
a result of the conversation and we did
manage to get out of it being kind and
nice to each other and agreeing that
we're not ever going to agree and that
you know he's you know but but he didn't
go back and go I'm going to quit leasing
cars you're a little tuber of wealth
manager is not going to quit using his
credit card no matter what you say so
just quit having the conversation is the
point it's useless I have I answer
questions for people that ask them not
for people who don't ask them that's
become a life-changing bit of wisdom for
me over the last few years I only answer
questions that I'm asked yeah and so my
friend the other day leased a car came
over to my house to show me his new car
it's a fabulous car by the way oh God
it's a great car
but he didn't come over there for me to
teach him about car leases he'd already
made his decision so I you know he
didn't say forgive me Father for I have
sinned he didn't do that he just brought
his stupid car over and I love his car
and I love him and and he's an idiot for
the way he bought it but the car is
amazing and I love him and that's great
and you know we've all got a friend
that's not smart and I got one too you
know and so but he's got a great car for
a little while while he rents it but you
know that's it and so you know know but
that you just got to decide what
conversations you're going to enter into
and I'm not going to sit and preach at
that guy it does no good he's got a car
sitting there why you think he's going
to take it back because Dave Ramsey
doesn't like it he's not going to take
it back he didn't ask my opinion
he just asked my opinion that I like the
color I do it's a beautiful car
there you go and you might go buy it
after he pays for all the depreciation
uh probably not that one but it's a good
car it was a fun conversation but yeah I
I
you know it's like my cousins are mine's
not but I have had that there's a
question over there is my cousin's a
whole life agent and he sold me the
whole life policy well you're not going
to talk your cousin into the idea that
whole life is sucks it does suck it's a
horrible product but you're not going to
talk a whole life agent into that fact
because he'd have to quit his job if he
had integrity and so this is a big
conversation you're not going to talk
him out of it but you can just explain
to them I'm no longer owning the policy
because that's my territory I get to
make decisions inside that fence and I'm
not gonna you know I'm not gonna play
anymore well you know we're not going to
talk about it anymore because you're not
going to talk him out of it and he's not
going to talk you into it if you're
smart right yeah it's walking away walk
away yeah walk away you can't teach you
to vote the right way we're not going to
talk about politics
it's just you know there's no reason to
argue you know Trump's crazy Biden can't
finish a sentence you know and Trump
Trump's the problem he probably caused
Biden not to be able to finish the
sentence and so you know by God they're
just all evil and they're oh the whole
thing well they're combined age is 156
there's part of the problem but yeah oh
my God but you know the the on you know
but you you people that fall on one side
or the other there is you just caused
about 114 wrecks in the United States of
America just said well add it up if
these two dupers run for president I
mean we're gonna have to have a he's
going to be sponsored by ensure it's
gonna be first sponsored by what's the
diaper the adult diapers yeah oh God
nursing home commercials everywhere this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today well the stock market's been up
the stock market's been down if you look
back 12 months ago it's about where it
was
but a lot of people say stuff like I've
lost all my money no I mean it's gone up
and gone down and we went up again and
then went back down again and it's
really sitting about where it was 12
months ago Dave I had that moment I
walked through where the TVs are on with
the ticker underneath it after all the
drama of the last few months I looked
like that's exactly where it was last
time I looked yep yep
uh here's the facts if you invest 200 a
month from age 25 to age 65 you would
have about two million dollars at
retirement
that's not too good to be true that's
based on the long-term average rate of
return of the s p
so you know if you make 12 on your money
100 bucks a month from age 25 to age 65
1 million 176 thousand dollars
100 bucks a month
so a huge predictor of investing is
not the rate of return
whether you become wealthy in investing
the number one predictor is that you
actually invest no way
we landed on the moon Lord a lot of
people talk a lot about investing and
have a lot of theories about investing
and they just don't do it they talk
about it and they thought well Ramsay
does this and says shouldn't say that
and I have an opinion and meanwhile I'm
just plunking money-wide plunking money
away plugging money away and a huge
predictor is that you actually invest so
you should get a pro in your corner to
find someone who can help you with your
investing with mutual funds go to
ramseysolutions.com smart investor we
will connect you with a smartvester pro
in your area they don't work for us but
these are people that follow the stuff
that we teach and they're in the
investment world
and most of all they have the heart of a
teacher and when you click on
smartvestor Pro
ramseysolutions.com it will drop down
a list of the smartvester pros in your
area you can interview all of them and
select the one you like best that's a
pretty cool thing
and I get somebody in your corner that
teaches you not pressures you when you
meet with an investment professional if
you smell salesman run if you smell
teacher lean in and learn and you're
ready and you'll end up buying there and
that's fine but you need to know what
you're putting money into don't do it
because I said to don't do it because
they said to do it because you
understand it it's a good investment
smart investors at ramseysolutions.com
smartvestor all right Sully is in
Raleigh hi Sully how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
how can I help
I was going to ask you about
um the Roth IRA and the 401K I'm not a
big believer in it
um I just don't know I've been always
afraid of it because we haven't had like
a great depression in a long time or you
know the economy just goes down so I've
always been thinking you know if I
invest my money in it
um there's going to come a time where
the economy is just going to collapse
and I'm just going to lose all my money
so I I have put tried it a couple of
times like right now I have like 1 600
but I don't know if I should get back
into it
okay
no you should not get back into it if
you believe it's going to collapse that
would be weird
right the only way you would get back
into it is if you got new information
that changed your mind about your
conclusion
I personally think your conclusion is
wrong
thus I invest because I think the
economy is going to go up over time it
does go up and down we were just talking
about that but overall
the economy has grown 11.2 percent the s
p has gone up 11.2 percent which is the
average of the stock market by the way
11.2 percent a year average for over 85
years
that includes the Great Depression by
the way
that's the average
do you think
um is like I'm looking at it like I'm
currently just buying like I bought my
house oh you bought a house
there's no guarantee with that house why
were you comfortable with that house
um I'm actually renting it I've been
renting it for a year and a half now and
I'm making like double the more but you
bought it
you're renting it or buying it he rented
it out and he bought it as a landlord
you're a landlord yeah
okay but I mean you bought this house
and it doesn't have a guarantee it's
going to go up what made you comfortable
that it was a good investment
because I
attention on it and I saw that I
actually went to so I'm current my
mortgage at 619 but I'm actually renting
it 1 300 and I'm making good money even
though I'm not taking any profit I'm
still trying to pay off the loan so what
happens when covet happens again and the
government says you cannot evict anybody
who chooses not to pay for 18 to 24
months
it just happened
yeah yeah that was just the other day I
think it's gonna happen again like is
there a possibility
so here's what we're doing exactly hey
here's the thing Sully that's ex you
know the weird thing is is you got all
this positive and optimistic view of
what real estate's going to do and
simultaneously you're convinced the
stock market's gonna crash
and uh but real estate you do have a
correct view of it not necessarily about
your renter but you look back and you
say gosh uh you know for the last 30
years real estate's gone up
real estate's generally been a good
investment and if you look at the math
on how much it's gone up in your area
you bought a house in an area that was
stable and had a good potential to go up
based on things that were happening
around it you looked at the facts and
the history and based on that you chose
to buy a piece of real estate because
you felt good about its future because
its history was good is that correct
yeah
three months the value of my house went
up thirty thousand some REM but you
missed the point yeah how old are you
I'm 22. okay well yeah yeah so here's
the thing Sully you need to study the
stock market it has a similar track
record of going up in value over a long
period of time to real estate both have
excellent histories of making people
money
and so you have a Poor Man's view of the
stock market and a rich man's view of
the real estate market you also have
what I'm going to call a delusional View
and I want you to learn this at 22 man
and I'm telling you from a guy that
screwed this up
you just said I've already made my this
much money on my investment in this
property because it has been evaluated
at a thirty thousand dollar increase
that's not real money until you sell
this house if you sell it tomorrow you
made thirty thousand dollars if you
didn't sell it you hadn't made anything
yet and so when it goes up or when it
goes down
it's not real money and it's not real
loss until you cash out and sell it my
house has gone up considerably because
I'm in Nashville Nashville bananas the
last few months that's not real money
until I choose to sell it since I don't
count that money I don't consider myself
a super like it's not real money man so
like Dave said you're choosing what you
want to look at positively and
negatively you got to look at all the
facts across the picture man you can't
just pick and choose or you're going to
bounce from thing to thing to thing to
thing to thing and you're gonna be the
guy with a basement full of Beanie
Babies and no money
oh it's Sully if you look it up in
history they're about the time you were
born there was a bunch of people buying
beanie babies and thought they were an
actual investment now my grandkids play
with them and the dog chews on them and
that kind of stuff so uh hey you know I
Warren Buffett most famously said you
know someone came up to him during the
2008 when the stock market went way down
they said Mr Buffett you know you lost
10 million dollars today on your
portfolio he said I didn't lose anything
and sell it
it went down in value but I didn't sell
it it'll come back up and then you'll
say Mr Buffett you made money now
it's just where it just went up and down
until I sell it I haven't locked in the
losses or the gains and so you got to
keep that in mind folks it's it's just
it's it's on paper until then and it
ain't green paper this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
4 23-24 be renewed in the spirit of your
minds and to put on the new self created
after the likeness of God in true
righteousness and holiness
Victor Frankel said when we are no
longer able to change a situation we are
challenged to change
ourselves Caitlin is with us Caitlin
Caitlin is in Seattle hi Caitlin how are
you
hi Andrew
good how can we help hi my question is
my husband and I are trying to decide
how much to spend when buying a house
with cash
um he himself my husband is
self-employed
um he's in the graphic design business
and you know with possible recessions
coming up or and there's you know with a
AI
impacting possible future business we're
just kind of our income's always sort of
Uncertain so we always stick with a
budget we always save everything we can
um love it but we are one of the house
with cash we're renting we've been
renting for a long time so how much cash
do you have of course
we have
um one million and seventy thousand
dollars
180 of it is in an I accept IRA
okay well 180 of it's not accessible
then how old are you guys
right okay so you have 800k and how much
do you have in your other Investments
not counting that
so we only have
um right now the
the total a million and seventy thousand
like that's including that and that's in
the bank right now because we're about
to buy a house we wanted to make sure it
was accessible right now
that's your entire net worth
yeah is one million seventy of which 180
is in the Sip
you don't have any other wealth because
you don't own a property now
and what's your household income now
right now our income
self-employed so it varied but
um 2020 we made 400 or so 20. what are
you thinking of spending on this house
um
area and that's kind of one of my the
big parts of my question
um
700 000 would be a good deal for a house
here
um and we're trying to decide if it's
absolutely crazy we're going to try to
shoot for 600 or something like that
it's just hit and miss trying to find
that I mean you do have two reasonable
pieces of data that are pulling at each
other on this one is Seattle is an
expensive market and 700 000 is not a
palace
okay it's a reasonable it's a mid-market
house right a little bit above
mid-market
um then the other piece of data is 700
is also almost all your money
right and that feels nervous
so yes it does
um what would Dave and Sharon Ramsey do
in your situation we would probably buy
something in the 500 range making 400
with a plan to move again in three to
five years and move up with more cash
okay
but I don't want the idea that I've got
80 percent of my entire net worth at
with a million dollar net worth tied up
in a single house that produces
absolutely no income does not sound fun
to me
that sounds high right
and so the 700 the 700 makes me nervous
it doesn't make me panic because you
make 400 and so the next year you
probably will Bank a couple hundred
right
yeah this year so far
um we're already at 175 000. yeah I mean
if you do that every year pretty quick
so let's say you bought something for
500 it's not what you want okay but
three years from now you could add 600
to it
and go by a million one pretty easy
and it will have gone up in value in
Seattle yeah
assuming you don't get in an inner city
area where your crime is so heavy and
you know anarchists are blasting out
your windows or something but I mean if
you get a reasonably solid neighborhood
a protected neighborhood you'll do fine
there Seattle is a great market in terms
of real estate and so yeah and as for
the other AI is going to disrupt
everything and all everything's coming
down
you can take two tracks on that man you
can continue just to consume and consume
and consume media and lose your mind
because again their goal isn't to tell
you the truth their goal is to get you
to click on stuff or you can do like me
and a couple of teammates did yesterday
we went and sat with the smartest guy
I've ever talked to in my life the data
analyst here and he taught us about how
it works and how it what wait the way
it's moving and we're just trying to be
informed about it right and so I can get
more data on it and get more facts on it
and I can also choose to just follow
principles until I know otherwise but
just choosing to sit in a circle and
panic and again that makes me
hyper nervous you're more stable than I
am but man putting my entire nest egg in
a house like that makes me yeah I think
I'd keep it down in the 500 range like I
said and then let's plant with a plan to
move up and would you take that other
500 or the other three two three hundred
and put it in a Mutual Fund mutual fund
ASAP yeah
absolutely and then and then and then I
would add to it and you know when she's
sitting there with a two million dollar
net worth and a million of it's in a
house at the next move right I feel fine
about that right and now we're getting
into a pretty nice property and if
you're a self-employed entrepreneurs and
you're making four or five hundred
thousand dollars a year don't forget
that you have proven to yourself that
you can figure stuff out and including a
uh whatever is coming down the pipe man
yeah we're so quick to forget our skill
set outside of I'm just locked into this
thing no you're you're that good the
first time you see that thing function
oh it's terrifying makes your breath
away that's terrifying as to what it'll
be able to do how many jobs it'll be
able to replace
right as long as these people strutting
around acting like they're worth
something an hour all of a sudden oh
nope gone nope gone gone no question
about it but on the other hand there's
going to be some ways that smart people
are able to use that and make the first
Fortune they ever made in their life
correct and ethically use it not and
there's a lot of unethical things that
can be done with it that'll
curl your hair too so it's going to be a
really interesting landscape next 14 18
months
um but what happens first in these type
of things by the way is the crooks come
out absolutely first first thing you see
and we're already seeing some of the uh
piracy things they're able to do with it
it's pretty amazing uh Neil deGrasse
Tyson wrote uh the fascinating piece the
other day about hey
he's gam he's betting on this is the end
of the end of the internet because it's
going to be so filled so fast with so
much garbage just like our friend who we
all know that just won't shut up he just
couldn't invite him to the party
and that there will be some sort of
pushed back to what's Twitter trusted
people Twitter it devolved into a sewage
discussion to where it was of no value
anymore and if computers are thinking
people have all left Twitter bidding
stuff out all over the place all the
time it's just gonna I'm just gonna go
talk to Dave because I chose that guy
you know what I mean it may uh it may
Revitalize stuff like this talk show
where people actually get to talk to
humans right yeah a lot like this show
needs to be revitalized it's doing fine
thank you very much and and I will say
this with some of the The Voice capture
technology you might be able to host
this show for another couple hundred
years it's fantastic
you know what that that in and of itself
is really scary
you know the Hologram yeah here we go ah
it's this is fun you're gonna be fine
Caitlyn uh you guys are smart people
dumb people don't make 400k
smart people know I know a couple yeah I
know a couple yeah I do too but in
general in general
um not not and you know you know how to
figure stuff out you know how to
navigate markets and your husband does
and the creative world and I think
you're going to be great
so but I would not put 80 90 of my one
million dollar net worth into a single
family
personal residence let me tell you let
me say this Dave and this is something
that came up in some of the research
articles I read I'm working on new book
I believe with all my heart when you're
about to do something that your body
knows is not a good idea it will begin
to Cascade that Stress and Anxiety
through your body you'll start to find
Sea fear everywhere and so when you
start thinking it's all coming down it's
all
that's your body trying to get your
attention that what you are doing and
what you're about to do probably is not
a wise idea yeah there you go or you're
on thin ice and you don't even know it
so let's get some wisdom good stuff good
show today Austin Ben James Zack and
Andrew and Dr John deloney I am Dave
Ramsey your host that puts this hour in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
foreign
[Music]
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]